- [Voiceover] Alright
so in the last video,
we were taking a look at
this multiple choice question
from the AP US History
exam practice booklet
and trying out some strategies
for making good choices
as you go through these questions.
Now the first thing we did was really
dive into the specifics
of what was happening
in both of these quotes.
Who James Henry Hammond is,
he's a governor of South Carolina
who was in favor of slavery
in the mid-19th century
who was giving some religious reasons
and reasons of kindness for why slavery
was a institution sanctioned
by God and society,
and Frederick Douglass,
famous abolitionist,
who's saying that slavery is the great sin
and shame of America.
So our first step was
analyzing the documents.
And then our second step was
to read each of our
questions really carefully.
And both the questions and
the possible answer choices,
you need to give them your full attention
because you might skip
over an important word
that makes the meaning different than what
you thought it was at first glance.
The third thing we're doing is going
through each of the options
and deciding whether
or not it's a possible
before eliminating it.
So let's try an example of
a multiple choice question
related to these documents.
The language used in both excerpts
most directly reflects the influence
of which of the following?
So they're specifically asking us
about the language.
That means, the words that they're using,
their phrases.
Not maybe their political positions
or the ideas that they're
trying to get across,
but specifically the words.
And we're looking for the influence
of one of these four ideologies.
OK, option A, The Second Great Awakening.
Hmm, alright, well, I'm gonna say
that's a religious movement of some kind.
And they both talk about God
and the relationship between
slavery and Christianity
so I'm gonna leave that as a possible.
Alright, what about States' rights?
Well, I imagine that both these people
would've had very different
ideas about states' rights,
but I'm not sure that's
what they're talking about
in these examples cuz
Hammond is talking about
the duty of slave owners to be kind,
and maybe the religious reasons why
God has made the institution
of slavery, in his opinion.
And Douglass is talking
about how slavery is
against the Bible and
against the idea of liberty,
so neither of them is
particularly concerned
with the political issue
of states' rights here.
So I think we can cross that one out.
Alright, Manifest Destiny.
Manifest Destiny was this
idea that the United States
had a divine mission to occupy
the North American continent
from Atlantic to Pacific.
While they both kind of talk
about ideas of divinity,
I don't think they're interested
in any kind of pioneering.
This is more connected
to the American West
than it is to any idea about slavery.
So I think we can get rid of that.
Alright, option D, American nationalism.
Well, I think Douglass is, if anything,
he's kind of saying
that slavery challenges
American nationalism.
Well I guess he talks about it then,
maybe a nationalist view
of the idea of liberty
would say that slavery
is a sin and a shame.
So that's possible for Douglass.
But what about for Hammond?
He's really making cultural
and religious arguments
for slavery, not any argument about
how slavery enhances the American nation.
So I'm gonna cross that one out too.
So that leaves us with The
Second Great Awakening.
And I think that is a good answer because
both of them are making
religious arguments.
They're saying that God would have liked,
or would not have liked, slavery.
So their language does reflect
an interest in religion.
We'll do some other
examples in other videos,
but I think the big takeaway from this is,
don't worry about having every idea
and every fact about American history
stored away in your brain somewhere.
Instead, understand that what
this exam is really going for
is finding out whether you
have a good overall idea
of what happened in American history,
and who might have supported which idea.
And trust your instincts.
They're usually right.
The point is not to test
you on some obscure outlier,
but rather to get a sense that you know
what you're talking about
in each era of history,
and the general idea of what was going on.
So use that to your advantage.
Understand the big, underlying themes.
And don't worry about the
little ticky-tack details.
You know what you're doing.